over the past months
without provocation or justification
russia has amassed more than a hundred
and fifty thousand troops around
ukraine's borders
in russia belarus
occupied
crimea russia says it's drawing down
those forces
we do not see that happening on the
ground
our information indicates clearly that
these forces
including ground troops aircraft ships
are preparing to launch an attack
against ukraine
in the coming days here's what the world
could expect to see unfold
in fact it's unfolding right now
today
as russia takes steps down the path to
war and reissued the threat of military
action
first
russia plans to manufacture a pretext
for its attack
this could be a violent event that
russia will blame on ukraine or an
outrageous accusation that russia will
level against the ukrainian government
we don't know exactly the form it will
take
it could be a fabricated so-called
terrorist bombing inside russia
the invented discovery of a mass grave
a staged drone strike against civilians
or a fake
even a real
attack using chemical weapons
so let me make this simple
the russian government can announce
today
with no qualification equivocation or
deflection
that russia will not invade ukraine
state it clearly
stated plainly to the world
and then demonstrate it
by sending your troops
your tanks your planes
back to their barracks and hangers and
sending your diplomats to the
negotiating table
in the coming days
the world will remember that commitment
or
the refusal to make it
i yield the floor
complexion
foreign
ukraine remains committed to peaceful
resolution of the russian ukrainian
conflict
by politica
diplomatic means
ukraine wants peace
security and stability
not only for itself but also for the
entire europe
at the same time i reiterate that in the
event of russia opting for escalation
ukraine will defend itself